tell me about when you wrote The Edge of
Glory who are you thinking about yeah
what is it about actually I wrote this
song it's kind of sad it's a little bit
of a downer but my grandpa died uh about
uh 6 months ago and it was the first
time I ever experienced death in my
family ever right we went out to New
Jersey remember I was really upset
because the paparazzi came and I just
thought to myself man you got to come to
my you got to come to a hospice yeah you
know and but your Grandpa didn't call
you Gaga did he my grandpa always just
called me baby you know my grandma calls
me Tuukka and uh what do your grandma
call you Tuukka tarala means uh sugar in
Italian all right Suella anyway so my my
grandpa was dying and my grandma was
there and I was really really you know
heartbroken because um you know my
parents are still married uh and my
mother and uh my mother's parents are
still married and my father's parents
are still married and my my grandma and
grandpa had been married for 60 years
wow and my grandmother um had never
slept with another man wow other than my
and you know she was a really is a
virtuous amazing woman and their love
story was so beautiful uh he my grandpa
used to sleep in a car outside her house
um just to be able to see her every day
wow um so anyway so when when my grandma
was saying goodbye you know there was
something so intense that happened for
me that I saw that you know as sad as
the moment was I felt like they both
were acknowledging that they had really
won in life Wow because they had each
other right so uh my you know my she
just kept saying you know Joey go just
go because she knew he was in so much
pain and um was really very strange um
he couldn't move but just to times when
I touched him and when my grandma
touched him he squeezed our hand so he
knew that we were there and I swear I
swear grandpa I know he's listening he
waited till I came home from tour to die
and the song came to you in that moment
in that well actually can you whip out
your phone I mean or is that rude what I
have it on my phone what happened was is
um that moment happened
right we left went home and then the
next day they said we think he's going
to pass
today and I could just tell that my dad
was really sad and my dad actually um
lost his sister when he was really young
so you know death in our F we're Italian
it's a big you know it's a big deal in
anyone's family but Italians you know
it's
like the whole you know the whole town
of poo and Sicily flew in for the
funeral you know so so anyway so my dad
and I sat at at the piano in our my in
my family's house and um we had this big
bottle of uh goave tequila and my dad
and I just started doing shots back and
forth and we were both crying and I just
kept saying dad you know you know
Grandpa's about to cross over into his
his glorious moment he's just it's just
hard now cuz he's on the edge right
right and I just started to play piano
and my dad started crying and you mean
it just came out of you the song it just
came right out and I just started
playing and I just remember my dad said
that's exactly what it is and in in a
way even though my dad's never like
written any lyrics or written any me
Melodies there were a lot of times when
I'd be playing and he would just be like
that's it kid that's it and uh it was
something about that moment with my dad
where he just for me to be able to
express what my father was feeling
without him being able to express I
think it was really special so then we
went back to the hospice and I had
recorded it on my phone and I played it
from my grandpa on the phone you feel
that maybe he heard it I know he heard
it